yes Secretary General di Antonio I'm
very very glad to welcome you here and
your team for the second time
last year when we had the first edition
we were at the beautiful Green Tree
estate in Long Island it was wonderful
it was insightful it was useful
so it's a pleasure now to consolidate
our joint meetings and I hope it's going
to become a tradition
our institutions the United Nations and
the European Union both transcend
National borders and national interests
we believe in the need for international
consensus and action
we need we believe in this need mainly
also because it is so necessary to
address the major Global challenges of
our time and indeed the world faces
unprecedented challenges
we have not even healed from the effects
of the pandemic when we were hit by the
devastating consequences of Russia's
aggression against Ukraine
there is of course the existential
threat posed by climate change but we
also see the economic and social
upheaval of the digital Revolution just
to name some of the main issues we know
both
that we can only tackle these through
International cooperation now more than
ever and in other words words this means
that the world needs the United Nations
now more than ever
I want to emphasize the European Union's
steadfast commitment to our strong
partnership
we have today and tomorrow a packed
agenda I want to speak about four topics
that are standing out
the first one is of course Ukraine
we will discuss our cooperation on in
support of Ukraine
but also in support of those who are
indirectly affected by Russia's Invasion
and here the big topic is of course the
grain expert from Ukraine to the world
we have in place our solidarity lanes
and they are complemented by your Black
Sea grain initiative
the solidarity Lanes have made it
possible for 45 tons of grain and Agri
food to be brought from Ukraine via the
European Union to the rest of the world
now we work very closely hand in hand to
bring grain and other food stuff to
those who need it badly
and Secretary General I want to thank
you for your tireless efforts to prolong
the Black Sea grain initiative the world
needs it
Russia has a responsibility to prolong
it otherwise Global Food insecurity will
be the consequence so now the ball is in
President Putin's court and the world is
watching
beyond the brain a Black Sea grain
initiative however there is in the
context of Russia's War one important
topic and that is the whole discussion
about and around upholding the U.N
Charter and the respect for the
international law and this goes to the
core of who we are and where our
institutions are built on
we do support president zelenski's peace
formula because it is based precisely on
the principles of the U.N Charter and
every single world word is deducted from
U.N resolutions so I look forward to
discussing that with you also how we can
gather Wide International support for it
the second big topic that we will be
discussing is climate change and our
preparations for cop28
the European Union is at the Forefront
of the clean energy transition and
Energy savings
we want to maintain our push for climate
ambition and we want to encourage the
world to follow suit
and this is why we propose to define
global Targets on Renewables and Energy
Efficiency we will discuss that tomorrow
this is in preparation of cop 28.
of course climate Finance is crucial
crucial for developing economies and
Emerging Markets
the massive Gap that we see still in
climate financing cannot be filled only
by public finances
we need the private sector
carbon pricing could also play an
important role
so these are all topics that we are
going to discuss tomorrow in depth
and the third topic is the global
digital transition the increasing power
of artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence is a revolution
and this revolution comes with enormous
economic and social impact on our
societies around the globe
on one hand we need to harness the
potential without any question because
it can increase prosperity and
well-being
on the other hand we also need to stay
very Vigilant regarding the effects of
AI the downside if you look at
information manipulation at foreign
interferences for example all the effect
artificial intelligence can have on our
society and the social cohesions
last but certainly not least we will
look at how we can re-energize Global
efforts to meet the sustainable
development goals by 2030 a big topic
the European Union is acting very
concretely on this already in particular
with our investment program global
gateway
here our Hallmark is that our investment
comes with high standards of openness
and good governance
and we think these are crucial
conditions for progress
to benefit the population at large and
to be sustainable over time
here too we share the understanding that
public sector financing needs to be
complemented by private sector financing
so here also we need to develop
Innovative instruments tools to promote
this
and we need to continue addressing the
increasing depth vulnerabilities of
developing countries
this was just a brief look at the big
topics that we are discussing a pact
agenda once again many thanks for coming
here I'm very much looking forward to
our retreat
thank you so very much for your warm
welcome and I'm indeed very happy to be
back in Brussels
and I thank president
and the European commission for hosting
the second unu high level dialogue
and this was the second but it will be
one of many that will happen every
single year
we are meeting at the time when
International cooperation is challenged
at its core
the Russian invasion of Ukraine has
shaken the region and the worlds
climate change is crippling countries
that contributed lists to causing it
and countless people escaping conflict
persecution and poverty are left to die
and then an even economic recovery from
covid-19 is exacerbating inequalities
and feeding mistrust between the global
West and the global South which finds
itself blocked from access to crucial
development Finance
this is when multilateralism is more
vital than ever
to bring peace to protect the planet to
end Hunger to build guard rails for new
technologies and I know that our two
organizations share these priorities
I'm grateful
for your contributions to our efforts
from climate action to sustainable
development from peace and security to
Human Rights and gender equality
and these now yearly dialogue is
Testament to the importance of our
partnership
we live in a never more multi-polar
worlds
and this calls for enhanced forms of
cooperation and multilateral governance
anchored in international law
and the European Union must be an
essential pillar of these new Global
Order
I
remember
my times in another capacity more than
20 years ago
when I was deeply committed
to strengthen
and to
Stronger integration of the European
Union
and it was my deep conviction that a
fundamental pillar of a multilateral
order is a strong and United European
Union
and together we must help breed
geopolitical divides and address these
Global challenges
it starts with rebuilding trust
particularly developing countries and we
do not have a moment to lose
to rescue the sustainable development
goals we need the transformation of the
Global Financial system so that it works
for everyone and fulfills its role as a
global safety net
and I see the European Union as a
potential engine for that transformation
based on equity and solidarity
on climate we need the international
cooperation for increased ambition on
both mitigation and climate Justice
I've appealed for a climate solidarity
pact in which all big emitters make
extra efforts to cut emissions and
glossier countries mobilize financial
and Technical Resources to support
emerging economies in a common effort to
keep the goal of 1.5 degrees alive
and once again I welcome what has been
the eu's ongoing commitment in these
regards
and finally we desperately need the
international action on new technologies
including artificial intelligence
governments visual organizations the
private sector and Civil Society must
come together to build common monitoring
and governance tools
so that technology serves human rights
and the common goods
on all these matters the world looks at
European Union that has always been a
Pioneer in promoting a digital world for
goods
and I know the Jerusalem that I can
count on your full support
I look forward to our discussions and I
thank you again for your warm welcome
and as you can witness after these two
interventions we I believe were close to
DuPont and DuPont
I love it
thank you very much